kosovo's former prime minister
and the frontrunner in sunday's
elections cast his ballot
early in the day with this message today
citizens of kosovo
are exercising their right to vote hopes
are high a lot of challenges ahead
but we are hopeful that we are going to
have a
high turnout and a great result
for democracy for state building
and for future development and progress
albin corti has promised to rebuild
kosovo
and its institutions kosovo is
struggling to gain international
recognition
since its declaration of independence
from serbia 13 years ago
it is one of the poorest regions in
europe and has been struggling
economically for decades
one in three people are unemployed and
the average person
earns about 11 dollars a day
kosovo's 1.8 million voters
will choose 120 legislators from
among 1 000 candidates courtes main
opponent
is a prime minister abu lahati from the
center right kosovo democratic league
in his short time in the office hoti has
struggled with the coronavirus pandemic
with numbers increasing particularly in
recent weeks
despite the continued spread of the
virus many of the candidates contesting
sunday's pools
have failed to adhere to social
distancing measures
and there are fears a high turnout could
spread the virus
even more nevertheless the message from
both albin courty who is former activist
and decedent
and abdullah khoty whose party has
dominated the political scene for many
years
was for people to turn up and vote
i'm calling on all the citizens that
have the right to vote to use this right
and to vote
today is their day today they will
express their free will
ninety percent of kosovars are ethnic
albanians
and since the region declared its
independence there have been u.s
and eu brokered attempts to mediate
between
kosovo and serbia those have failed and
if court evince
analysts predict that hopes of reaching
a settlement could
further diminish but relations with
serbia
and potential membership in western
bodies and organizations
like nato and the european union have
not featured highly on the agenda during
the campaign
instead the focus has been mainly on the
economy
the main challenge for whoever wins
these elections will be to regain the
people's trust in the government and its
institutions
and to do that it would seem the new
leader will have to find the solution to
kosovo's economic problems
ognizorich al-jazeera pristina